[Music]
it's snowing out a little
snowing white christmas
i know what's going to happen any day
now
so the plan that they came up with was
rather ingenious
they decided to take paul castellano out
by luring him to one of his favorite
restaurants
with captains that he absolutely trusted
their scheme was all the shooters and
they had many of them because they
wanted to be able to pull this off we're
gonna be in trench coats
russian hats you see that a lot in new
york and it's just so
nothing no one's really going to pay
attention to anything if anything
they'll focus on well there's a guy with
a trench coat and a russian hat i can't
tell you anything else about it
one of the busiest sections of midtown
manhattan four o'clock in the afternoon
around the holidays so
john gotti was in the car up the corner
with sammy the boat
he hated paul so much that he wanted to
see him laying in the street
i happened to be at another guy i was at
dinner at his house sitting at the
kitchen table and he had a little
television on the table
and while we're sitting eating we get
some 9-1-1
taxes on our beepers back in those days
beepers
and i kept getting them 9-1-1 9-1-1
[Music]
and behind the 9-1-1 i'm getting 9-8
that means
come to the club on 98th street or
bergen
so i know something happened
[Music]
it's all over the news it's flashed
everywhere that paul castellano was hit
in front of spark's steakhouse
big paul castellano reputed godfather of
the gambino family was on his way to a
manhattan steakhouse
as he stepped from his black lincoln
three men wearing fur hats and trench
coats suddenly appeared
pulled guns pumped six bullets into
castellano
and six into his top couple thomas
belotti and then calmly walked away
i was upstairs in my room and all of a
sudden on the news
i'm hearing you know paul castellano
mob boss is killed outside sparks
steakhouse
and i'm thinking like wow who could have
done this
after the hit sammy gravano and john
gotti drove the car down the street
and they slowed up and looked at the
bodies and kept on going
[Music]
because he was he was a gangster and he
wanted to be there
and see it for his own eyes
and then john was the boss
[Music]
the old-time mob bosses you say you know
they they rule with an iron fist
covered with a velvet glove well gotti
saw no need for the glove
that's what it came down to this was a
hostile takeover
in in every sense of the word
after he was killed and john became the
boss
all the heroin dealers that were around
john all got straightened out
[Music]
daddy was a boss who reflected the times
he was always grabbing and reaching for
more and more
[Music]
so by the time we reach about 1986 1987
we expand the heroin business into the
cocaine business
i have colombian connections so we're
coming in from columbia
there's loads coming in from miami
coming in from detroit
the allure was money and very easy money
if you've got the connections it's about
the logistics
it was money so we go out to the
hamptons fire island party drink
uh broads champagne flowing from the
morning till night
listen when you have keys to the city
like john gotti did
he was arrogant he didn't care that he
broke every rule
you know this is supposed to be
cozonosta our thing when john gotti took
over
it was no longer our thing it was my
thing
his transformation was like a
caterpillar turning into a butterfly
no sudden he's wearing three thousand
dollar ties and the cocoon opens and out
comes
the dapadan he's out and about he's good
with a quip and a sound bite
why did you just behave yourself i'm
behaving myself
john gotti changes the whole dynamic of
organized crime
no longer the old sicilian style make
money not headlines stay in the shadows
the idea was what's the point of being a
gangster if nobody knows who you are
every fourth of july he throws a free
fireworks bash for the neighborhood
when police have tried to stop it the
crowds have driven them back
gotti is somewhat of a local hero here
ironically the neighborhood thinks john
gotti's keeping the drug dealers out of
here
yet john gotti's a drug dealer but he's
not the guy peddling it on the street
right so it's the perception he's saving
us from drug dealers no he's not
gotti was every day in your face look at
me i'm a gangster doing this
and that drives law enforcement
[Music]
you